in a muddy Dutch field the reality of a
constant Christmas controversy
here the slow-moving munching mechanical
caterpillars are relentlessly harvesting
Britain's most divisive vegetable
the Brussels sprout
in the Netherlands the little Sprout is
very big business
Federica is the third generation of her
family to harvest Sprouts this year has
been a tough one
and in the summer it was very dry
um so we need to irrigate the Sprouts we
need to give fertilizer love to the
Sprouts of course
also the coasts are quite everything is
expensive labor fertilizer chemicals
everything you need for Sprouts
Britain supermarkets will sell about 750
million Sprouts over Christmas only half
will actually be eaten right here is
where this Brussels sprout starts its
life on a farm in the Netherlands but
now it begins its grueling journey to
you going from field to Fork
the Sprouts are taken here to a factory
half an hour away it's a Labyrinth of
machines to sort out sprouts
the biggest go to Germany the Dutch like
the small ones and these are the ones
destined for Britain
so
what they make them I think ready
because they are fine
not too big not too small I think
they all go through this machine it
scans sprouts for imperfections and Jack
is watching out for any badons it's just
like a puzzle you have to find the the
spray what is not good and then with
this you're gonna play the colors
the Dutch grow more Sprouts than anyone
else they've even changed the taste to
suit British pallets that prefer sweet
over bitter it is a huge effort to tout
the Sprout and despite all that some of
you still won't eat them Adam Parson Sky
News Holland